[Music]
this tow truck can haul a vehicle as
large as a semi-truck the towing
apparatus is called the under lift this
is one of four outriggers these legs
stabilize the tow truck when it's using
the recovery boom
these hydraulically powered towing and
recovery machines are made up of 2,500
parts cut from steel sheets the parts
are cut by one of two types of computer
guided machines a high-pressure water
jet cutter as we're seeing here or a
laser cutter then tack weld them
together
[Music]
tack welding is an initial welding in
select spots just to hold the parts
together until a robot does the final
welding next workers sandblast the
welded component this preps the surface
for painting the paint dries in about
two hours and fully cures in about two
days workers hook up all of the
hydraulically powered components to this
testing machine workers connect
permanent hydraulic lines to assemble
the recovery boom they install hydraulic
cylinders that will move it up and down
a winch that winds and unwinds the thick
wire ropes and an enormous ring gear
that enables the boom to rotate 360
degrees
[Music]
then they attach the extendable boom
[Music]
it's secured with massive steel pins
[Music]
workers also attach the under lift at
the back and the for stabilizing
outriggers underneath this completes the
towing and recovery unit now they attach
it to a pre-built truck steel mounting
plates are bolted to the trucks frame
the towing and recovery unit is then
welded to those plates workers bolt
aluminum tool cabinets to the side of
the trucks frame
[Music]
inside the cabinet they make the wiring
connections for the emergency lights and
other electrical components
[Music]
they install the electronic control
panel that the driver uses to operate
everything the control panel monitors
oil temperature hydraulic pressure and
other important indicators they also
install a set of control handles to give
the driver the option of manual
operation once everything is hooked up
they perform a quality control
inspection
[Music]